foreign
[Music]
waiting for the phone to ring to hit me
with an update on the miracle
the steps are pretty simple but
depression makes this dance craze much
more typical
that's always some frustration that's
part of the appeal let's finish up the
holiday let's see how we feel
[Music]
we get so personal
and it's hard for him to Fathom what
more he could have done ask the server
put a setup but the closure Never Comes
so much for taking safety and municipals
she's got a couple lovers you're not the
only one
you're just the only one that went up to
the roof with her
and it's too much information yes
circuit board is Jam break up in potato
that was probably not the plan
staggered by this newest piece of truth
from her
thank you
I met up with some rippers that were
napping on the scaffolds of the City
Beach
I asked him if they knew somewhere that
he could get an update for the software
suite
given Shawnee for the number they gave
zero guarantees so we need some new
distraction she guesses she agrees
but she wishes that he won tickets so
personal
sometimes there's some safety and
reciprocals these millionaires are
mostly in the multiples maybe try the
guys
[Music]
are kind of messy and the weather wasn't
great
but still gonna stay here till the
packages
it's a Sicky situation it's the bottom
of the pan this Township burning
circuits in a mediocre man
maybe we're just better off as party
frowns
in a part-time by the water poured
bubbles in the wrong so she's got a
couple lovers you're not the only one
you're just the only one that wants to
spend the week with me
we had a condo in a complex off the
Causeway by the beach waiting for the
phone call watching all the TV
you're just the only one that wants to
spend the week with me waiting out the
weekend and potato King
[Music]
[Applause]